foreign
brothers and sisters I'm at the mecca
Center and I'm at a sleep physician and
he shared something just really amazing
with me a latest discovery about
sleeping on your side can you share that
with us yeah so subhanallah as we know
the prophet salallahu told us that the
best body position for sleep is to sleep
on the right side so the Sunnah the
prophet saws to sleep on the right side
and now it has been proven
scientifically by people who are
non-muslims by
American scientists that sleeping on the
right side sleeping on the side
especially the right side is the
healthiest position for sleep it
especially the right side especially the
right side that's in Islam that's what
Muhammad he expressed right absolutely
absolutely absolutely how do you tell us
to sleep on the right side and the
science also proves this and two things
have have been shown one is there's this
condition called sleep apnea and this
tends to be worse when people sleep on
their back so when one sleeps on the
side it's less like to happen especially
the right side
uh the other thing is there's this we
have discovered recently that there's a
system in the brain that clears uh gets
rid of wastes that accumulates during
the day and the best position but the
position during sleep is is to sleep on
the right side and that helps it enables
the system to get rid of all the waste
that accumulate during the day
so this is what we have found out so far
but who knows there may be other things
that science in the future will prove
subhanallah everything that we read in
the Quran everything that we read in the
Sunnah when something comes out in
science it proves that the Quran and the
Sunnah are from the Quran it's authentic
and the hadees from the prophet sallam
is also an accuracy
there's so many things that science
proves and we see the origin of it in
the Quran and another thing that we we
have learned is if somebody uses the
mouth and throat muscles that helps
protect from sleep apnea also
as we know in in Islam we encourage
people to read the Quran to practice at
tajweed and that read uses pretty much
every muscle in the throat and in the
mouth it strengthen these muscles and
also helps
protect the body from this condition
that can affect breathing during stop
and is doing sleep and it's detrimental
health
so subhanallah there's a lot of things
thank you for sharing those few gems
with us yeah no problem there's a lot of
things and subhanallah we just have to
look carefully we have to look at this
and look at science and there is no
there's no contradiction between the two
absolutely
we've been told that they're out to kill
us all assalamualaikum brothers and
sisters we went to the streets to ask
Americans about Islam here's what they
said do you know anything about Islam No
do you know anything about Islam No
sadly do you know anything about Islam
uh not really do you know anything about
Islam
no sorry you know what Islam means Islam
uh no we've been told that uh they're
out to kill us all right that's what
you've been told that Muslims are out to
kill you all
well that's what they say on TV
anything
I know it's in the Middle East isn't it
well then you're going to have four
wives brothers and sisters as you can
see there are so many Americans who
don't know about Islam we need your help
to change that help us to build the dean
Center the first mega dawa Center in
America click the Donate right now may
God Almighty Allah reward all of you
foreign
[Music]
foreign